there are five exceptional lead groups
associated with the octonials these are
denoted G2 F4 E6 E7 and E8 with G2 being
the smallest and E8 being the largest
subgroups of these groups show
remarkable overlaps with the group's
su-3 su-2 and U1 which arise in particle
physics as well as engaged theoretic
approaches to general relativity
octionic Maps can be used to generate
Clifford algebras and Spinners made from
these algebras so precisely the
properties and symmetries observed in
quarks and leptons of the standard model
the octonians also label non-commutative
manifolds which generalize the
space-time manifold of the classical
Universe this raises the possibility
that a matrix valued classical Dynamic
on the octoniotic geometry is the
precursor of quantum theory and of
space-time geometry as also a possible
theory of unification there has also
emerged a deep connection between
autonions and twister theories negations
of unification with autonions will be
discussed in the forthcoming lecture
series all smu-23 Link in the
description